there's stuff on this side that I don't
really know because I don't really see
it ever no I don't even like I'm just
like it's there I was 17 when I got my
first tattoo I hid it from my parents
for a very long time I don't feel like I
even needed parental consent I don't
even remember where I got it but not
super legit I think I got it like an eco
sign which is it's kind of like a circle
with a line through it but it like looks
like 16-bit you know so you have to you
enough explain to somebody what it was
it's not a particularly that well done
like I probably would have done that a
little differently this right before I
had my first kid and I was just like
thinking about it constantly and there
is this statue that gets hung and in
little boy's rooms in Japan that like
instrument' inspire bravery I went over
to John Mayer's house he had this
Japanese artist who was doing the tattoo
but the guy like really didn't speak any
English I remember talking to him the
artist and I was like I want to have
like crazy waves on one side and they're
kind of calm waves and the other side
like just the idea that I was like maybe
this with like parenthood will kind of
be like having a kid you know or
whatever and he was like no calm waves
in Japan I was like sure let's just do
crazy waves
[Music]
the world and the land you know and the
idea that was created and the fact that
it was like this Disney movie but it was
so subversive I always thought was
really cool this is also representative
of one of my biggest tattoo issues and
that is that I literally hate getting
tattooed so much so it's really
unfinished everyone's like oh it's cool
how there's like no color or whatever
I'm like well they're supposed to be
color I just have never finished it so
there's Jack and zero-zero kind of like
starts it and there's Sally over here I
didn't want it to be like it's not
really like a sad sleeve or anything you
know though there is a broken heart
there cuz she you know once Jack and
Jack wants Christmas there's it ghosts I
think that was gonna stay kind of faded
there's pumpkins gonna pumpkins
there's the mayor who is like one of the
greatest and most underrated characters
the vampires over here maybe I'll get it
finished at some point I guess this is
one of my favorite tattoos this howl
from Howl's Moving Castle he's just such
a relatable antihero to me you know like
he's like going to like save his world
but then his haircut like doesn't look
right and she just is like I'm so sad I
wanted I felt kind of relatable me and
my brother both got this uh tiger tattoo
right here I just learned that there's
more Tigers in people's backyards in
Texas in our in the wild google it it
sort of like really crazy fact twenties
from the silly bear I wrote this lullaby
for my
one of my kids and that's just some of
the lyrics from it yeah I had friends
that were in hardcore bands in Syracuse
New York they've had this tattoo spot
called halo tattoo they do a lot of like
chronic thorns and that are particularly
religious person and I'm just like like
how the crown kind of looks and it
connects to this piece of my upper back
that my friend Mike Suzuki did he's
saying this bands brother's keeper and
he just did this weird bomb hardcore
tattoo on me which I thought was cool
the time I got this tattoo this keyhole
tattoo like around the time we put out
from rid of the Cork Tree I don't
remember I think I've said once before
that I got it like when I read it I
don't think that's actually true I can't
picture getting a face tattoo my mom
would like literally murder me I think
not what post Malone this weekend his it
looks normal because it's like you can
tell it's authentic like to him the host
of this tattoo show on oxygen for a
while and like when people owned it and
like the tattoos were important to them
the tattoo would come off in a different
way than if you were like yeah I'm like
wishy-washy I wouldn't get a tattoo if
you're wishy-washy about it